good morning believe nation today's
message is find happiness and over to
you Lilly Singh I was in my last year of
university just going through a really
tough time I was really doing anything
for myself and then I discovered you too
but I remember the first time I saw
videos like this thing this magical
thing on the internet and so I uploaded
a video spontaneously I kept doing it
simply because it made me happy it made
a sad person happy I've learned
happiness is the hardest thing you will
ever fight for your life is the only
thing worth fighting for in your life
everyone's been sad everyone's been
through things but I think it's really
what you do with those feelings and you
do with those dark times and the ability
to change them into something beautiful
so what do you think this girl is seeing
I love the video because she did her
worth is happiness and happiness is what
the world needs like to be more fun and
creative
just like the belle your kids around you
I mean if you have family with little or
kids of your own so they're always
joyful and they're always like playful
and that's the happiness we need to find
within us to be like more happy with
yourself embrace everything we've got
and believe in yourself more than like
anyone in the world something like that
because if you don't believe in yourself
no one else will so you have to believe
enough like to make others believe in
you so my advice to whoever is watching
write three things for which you are
grateful for just for writing it it will
make you like really come out alive and
be happier and
with gratitude with what you already
have or what you are trying to achieve
in your lives so I agree I love
gratitude I have a daily practice that
I've put in for the past couple years of
three things that I'm grateful for every
morning I brought it to my team we
brought it to YouTube as well and I
think it's really important that a lot
of times the things that make you happy
may not make sense yet like you don't
understand how do I turn this thing that
makes me so happy
into a business or a career because it
may not be totally laid out you know so
for me I love helping entrepreneurs and
the first thing they did was having a
seminar to help entrepreneurs Emilee
three people showed up to my free
seminar and I thought if only three
people show up to a free thing how am I
ever gonna make a business out of this
how is that ever gonna happen right
logically it doesn't make sense but I
just love doing it so much it filled me
with so much joy helping entrepreneurs
having new entrepreneurs on the channel
like I love doing it and so I had to
find a way to keep going and I
eventually figured it out eventually
built a website eventually built a
YouTube channel you know the execution
of it I figured out what time and I
think if you have something that brings
you joy that brings you happiness you
owe it to yourself to continue down that
path to try to figure out how to turn it
into something that could be amazing for
you even if it doesn't make total sense
yet right now because that's way better
than you thinking okay well I can never
make that a success and so I'm going to
just get this job that I hate doing and
just stay there for us in my life and
never be happy I think too many people
do that
I think tuning people wake up when they
drive to a job that they hate everyday
and they never get to express themselves
or be creative or have that joy your
freedom and so when you find that thing
that makes you happy
find a way to keep that as a part of
your life every day build some momentum
towards it every single day and if you
do that some amazing things will happen
so the question of the day today is when
you think about happiness what three
things comes to your mind leave it in
the comments below we're going to join
in the discussion so thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed and
have a
amazing day we believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I will see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
and
what did you do if you did three like
this yeah like this wow I would do I do
this
Canada Venezuela okay what three or
three things